les années défilent mais andré robillard
ne change pas ce personnage haut en
couleur et fantasque jusqu'au fond de
son âme cela lui permet quand ils
découvrent l'exposition qui lui est
consacrée de garder un oeil décalé sur
sa production et son statut que c'est
chez les choses que quelques questions
libérant des clubs que j'aime que je
pars momen gênés puis des fusils puis
après j'ai continué à faire des animaux
bien après que les planètes et
maintenant je mets artistes à ce l'on
m'a dit que j'étais artiste
robillard né en 1931 gien aura passé la
quasi intégralité de sa vie dans cet
hôpital spécialisé de fleury les aubrais
il y est depuis le début des années 40
parce que le divorce de ses parents et
la séparation avec sa mère en fait un
enfant perturber sa rédemption s'opère
dans les années 60 au hasard d'un
atelier de création au sein de l'hôpital
il a fait une sorte de jeu à ce moment
là
réunissant trois bouts de ficelle et
trois bouts de bois et
une conserve et voilà et donc quelqu'un
d'intelligent d'abord son contremaître
vivent les contremaîtres quillan le goût
de l'art quelque sorte qu'ils sont
aperçus que c'était une curiosité qui
peuvent avoir certaines valeurs il
emmène sa contre m au sens psychiatrique
chef paul renard qui l'enverrait
dubuffet andré robillard et tenait jean
dubuffet figure majeure de l'art moderne
adoubant dre robillard mais le patient
de l'hôpital d'auch maison at en 1976
pour créer d'autres fusils référence à
son père garde-chasse depuis lors ils
fabriquent des assemblages issue
d'objets recyclés et se passe temps
s'avère être sa meilleure thérapie il a
un logement à l'hôpital mais il n'a pas
de suivi psychiatrique du tout donc là
il a trouvé tout à fait un équilibre il
a une vie de retraité comme comme tout à
chacun tranquille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
papy peinard consacré citoyen d'honneur
de fleury-les-aubrais peut-être la
figure la plus internationale de la
ville car andré robillard est
aujourd'hui exposée à paris lausanne new
york
[Applaudissements]